check who's uh
who's running the show he didn't want
that
okay well i think i should just crack on
and start
any uh
just check
all good
go
thumbs up okay we're on uh
great to be
back in person i am
my head is still in a spin from seeing
real people um i
i i'm not used to this at all
and
uh i i got my um
got my vaccine one got my vaccine too
got my vac vaccine optimistically got my
vaccine three on monday
and have been wiped out since then so i
spent uh two days uh solid sleeping
uh and uh so if i feel a little bit out
of out of sync you'll know that i'm just
just getting back to normal
uh
it yeah it's really really wonderful to
have us back together in in person and
uh it's been uh one pandemic and two
language versions for me
uh so
um
it's it's been a productive productive
time i'm actually really
happy with uh how
just how far we've been able to progress
uh things in the world of f sharp and
i'm just going to kind of take you on a
gentle walk through what we've been
doing since march 2018
and
even
one of the features we worked on i
really like this it kind of brackets the
whole thing for me
one of the features which i'll be
talking about
actually came directly from the very
last f-sharp london
meetup
that we had in february 2020 and we got
together we talked about someone gave a
talk nick blair gave a talk on a flick
what he called applicatives
and i thought
yes we should finally do
the thing in the language to give proper
support to this thing and so you know
there's a whole story here about how f
sharp five and f sharp six have come
about and i just wanted to talk you
through uh what we've been doing it's a
very uh informal talk
and i'll be giving lots of demos along
the way but the first uh part of the
talk is actually a little bit different
which is uh we've also done some changes
to how we talk about f sharp and this um
and i thought i'd just kind of
bring this up as a topic you can talk
about it amongst uh
between us all
afterwards and as we go and they're an
important set of changes that came
through our work with the.net foundation
and the f-sharp software foundation
and uh through some of the people at
microsoft as well though the binom this
is absolutely collaboration with the
community as well
and uh it's sort of a marketing exercise
that a few of us did the people uh in
charge of dot net and the net foundation
and and uh microsoft kind of said to us
look
uh
you know we understand f sharp it's
absolutely fantastic and it but do you
have to talk you have to make the
functional thing about f sharp so
central to your messaging the way you
talk
about f sharp because
we understand that for people who get
functional programming
uh that that makes sense but that you
know the value that you're bringing
can be lost on other people who don't
understand who don't who don't who who
actually could be benefiting from what
you've got here but you're not reaching
them with the messaging you're using
and so
uh they asked us to kind of say go go go
right from the right and back to the
start about how you talk about f sharp
and we and and i sat down with philip
carter with scott hunter of the of uh
microsoft
uh with nicholas gustafsson uh also reid
copsy isaac abraham and others
and we started talking about who we
really aiming at besides
the kind of
you know besides the people already
using f sharp who we who are we kind of
talking about and there's two really big
target markets which
uh are more indicators
they actually apply to pretty much every
other programming language in the world
so in a sense we're after everyone
but uh
we use these two groups as our kind of
initial kind of starting point uh well
after python programs but we're not
after all python programmers okay the
great thing about python programmers is
there's so many of them in the world you
only need to be able to address like one
percent of them to have a really huge
number of programmers right okay uh so
but python programmers are absolutely
hitting limitations okay
they hit limitations with respect to
typing and they hit limitations with
respect to performance in particular if
you write over five or ten thousand
lines of python code you're you you
start you're really in trouble with
regard to a lack of static typing okay
if you uh
uh
if
very large chunks of python code end up
being moved across into c plus
because of performance issues okay
and we and those of us programming in
c-sharp and f-sharp and net know that
that doesn't have to be the case okay so
python programs are hitting the limits
cjr program has been interesting and
look c sharp is an amazing language it's
been it's progressed so far over the
last year from when i first engaged with
it in c sharp 1.0 it's just
it's been on a long journey of its own
to try to stop being what it originally
was and become something else okay
and uh and that's
that is really
uh
really amazing but there are c-sharp
programmers who who frankly get a bit
fed up with the whole
object-oriented
thing and they look over towards the
python world and they think
i want that succinctness you know i want
that kind of data orientation i want
that scripting i uh
uh
there's a whole lot of aspects which
although c sharp is working hard to get
them into the into c sharp they're not
there in the sort of practical
experience of using the language
day-to-day
and so they think well actually i just
might leave the whole.net ecosystem
right and and go and go go and go go
or go uh python or whatever else they
they think they'll do and we and we
think that doesn't have to be the case
that actually the net ecosystem can
offer
alternative views on
programming
and that f sharp represents this really
sweet spot between the worlds of of of
of sort of succinct programming and
succinct data oriented programming and
transition into fully statically
strongly typed programming uh as
interoperable programming
so we we we did a marketing exercise
where we think okay there are target
markets we want to write down all the
technical features and qualities of
fsharp i haven't got the original of
this uh i've lost that but
and then we kind of marked them up for
relevance to the different target
markets okay is this relevant to c-sharp
programmers is this relevant to f-sharp
programmers and we just sort of chose
the top three more or less
and something like this it wasn't this
one and so we might for instance say
okay here are these qualities sickness
robustness performance expressiveness
interoperable and we started group we
listed like 20 30 of them and we kind of
bucketed them and so on and yes we
sometimes we found ourselves listing
qualities and then there are different
features under those so what supports
succinctness in fsharp well you have
amazing type inference it's expression
oriented you have two pools you have
active you know there are
there are features that support uh
equality and experience
and robustness okay no nulls uh
functional abstraction
types and so on unless you write robust
uh code
reusable code and then um and so on
typed code generics without boxing and
so on uh with performance
and
what appeals to python developers well
actually the first group don't
automatically appeal to they're kind of
table stakes for python developers they
they'd say well of course you want
programming to be like that no one would
want it to be any other way so that's
just the minimum that they need but then
there are these other things like this
robustness which kind of really appeals
and appeals and then in c-sharp it's
actually the opposite kind of
c-sharp devs have a lot of great things
with regard to robustness and
performance but they they lack on that
first kind of succinct this kind of
thing
and
and so
we
there are some things we didn't include
in the in in the top three like if we
don't say for instance expressiveness or
interoperability or they're great
qualities of f sharp and you should
always
think have them in mind in talking about
f sharp but you've got a
limiting to three is a good thing and so
we chose these three themes succinct
robust and performant and so when you
see any core messaging around f sharp
uh
let's throw glasses on and off if you
see any core messaging around f sharp
say in fsharp.org for the f sharp
software foundation
fsharp empowers everyone to write
succinct robust and performant code
that's the core message that we have and
you can kind of see it gives you the
simplicity and succinctness like python
with the correctness robust and
performance beyond c-sharp and java
and then all the other things you want
to talk about open source cross-platform
free
targets javascript targets.net
uh and what it can be used for
and that goes through the
the the microsoft messaging around f
sharp uh and docs.microsoft.com
so if we go
fsharp.net or something
then you'll see
this is one of the landing pages open
source language that makes it easy to
write succinct robust and performant
code
i'm mapping that through
okay
so
so those are a change in how we talk
about fsharp and it's perhaps
as important as what we've done in the
technical work
and
part of the my change in thinking about
uh
about f sharp was really influenced by
this
image that got tweeted around by isaac
abram and it's based on somebody else's
image and then extend it out uh to
to to to the right and it's it's
reminding people that there's this
eternal sweet spot of programming which
is functions and data
and it's not even plus types
the types are there the use of types
is there to support that sweet spot of
functions and data okay so everything is
trying to keep you in that sweet spot
and get as much of your programming as
possible in the world of
fairly simple functions and fairly
simple data that's always been what f
sharp has been about it's also what
python is great at it just doesn't have
a very good story with regard to types
and performance and other things okay
you do need a whole bunch of other
characteristics but in the end there's
forever and ever and ever there will be
this sweet spot of programming which is
about functions and data what happens
with people is they start in this sweet
spot and they love programming they
think it's amazing and then they go off
on this big object-oriented kind of
thing and they learn their design
patterns and do object objects
everywhere and they learn about
abstraction and interfaces you know and
i might i might you know planning for
future change and everything like that
and then they
and then they find you know most of that
some of that is valuable i'm not it's an
80 20 thing all the way along the sweet
spot is 80 and then there's this 20
where you need your object orientation
and your your object programming and so
you go through that and you you you and
then you real you learn oh okay you
finally get back to this world of
functions and data
as being sort of the main focal point of
your mind and the other this other stuff
you've learned still helps you but you
learn to use it appropriately you learn
to moderate it okay
and so
function you're back to all the
functions of data and then you discover
functional programming and you start
going oh my god you start learning all
about monads and applicatives i'll even
be talking about applicatives today
category theory effects and everything
and a similar kind of thing kind of
happens in a different dimension
of functional programming and then
eventually you do get back to this world
of functions and data and that is the
world where f sharp is is focusing on
and uh it's it's one of the
one of the reasons why sometimes people
come to f sharp and they think wow i
don't have everything in i don't i can't
for instance declare protected members
in sharp i don't have everything i have
in the object world well there's a
reason for that it's we're trying to
keep you in the sweet spot
okay we're trying to keep you in the
sweet spot of functions and data and
then they they come then then they go
learn the haskell or something else or
actor or something and they they learn
they've got all these amazing things to
play with and they say i can't wear my
toys you know they
throw a tantrum and say you know this
this isn't as as big and powerful as my
other functional language so you know
but that there's a reason for it which
is we keep you in the sweet spot we keep
you in the productive spot and
everything we are doing uh in fact five
and six and all the way through is about
keeping you in that spot
okay so uh
as part of the messaging uh change
around f sharp we also kind of tackle
this question of sort of what is f sharp
good at what is it for people ask that
question it's quite naturally and we do
these days we give a really simple
answer to that which is f is good for
programming okay okay and we we don't
beat around the bush we said it's good
for absolutely everything okay
uh and we we might qualify that we might
say it's good for uh and then and this
is um
this is some of the f sharp community
dave thomas and others who just
started answering questions on
formatting on forums
about about you know what is fsharp good
for you just like airshot's good for
programming
so it does keep it simple uh fsharp's
good for web programming f2l is good for
cloud programming ai ml data science
whatever you like uh we might talk about
its qualities that we talked about
before robust correct and performant so
synced correct and performant
programming but basically fsharp's good
for
programming uh and uh in more recent
material uh since we're doing a full
revamp you know we're just on the f
sharp getting started kind of material
you just see the emphasis on this
command line.net new lang fsharp.net
build you know f sharp tools being part
of everywhere we might talk about f
sharp for the web back end
uh using say giraffe or some of the
other options around for web backend but
it's a very simple similar story install
the templates.net new giraffe
sorry that should be.net new giraffe on
this slide and you get a fantastic hyper
functional server-side programming
and f-sharp for the web front-end using
javascript similar story
targeting f-sharp to javascript
and this uh this story for theft is a
javascript language it's really really
good i uh one of the sessions i got to
do this year was to take the designer of
python guido von russem uh and you might
have seen at the dot net conf days on f
sharp you can see the recording on the
web i recorded an online session with
guido where i teach him some f sharp
code
and guido is actually doing some client
server programming he's actually hasn't
done much web programming in his life
you might be surprised to hear
and certainly not much client side uh
and he's and he's he's doing some uh f
sharp on the client side and smash up on
the server side and he he doesn't he
doesn't know which it doesn't matter
which side he's working on he's just
doing a shop code on on either side all
the tooling works really really nicely
and uh so f sharp is also a javascript
language so and you can do f sharp for
the for for the for the full stack with
something like safe for some other
options you can use
a new safe template
and there might be f sharp for data
science and ml uh with this sort of
getting started material using notebooks
and and a few packages
okay
right so that's just an update on how we
talk about fsharp how we think about it
and what it's you know it's it
there's in a sense there's been no
change because this is exactly what f
sharp has been about all along okay it's
just being a little bit more explicit
about what f what f sharp is and what is
trying to support and do
okay
now i get to talk to you about f sharp
five and f sharp six some kind of change
mode and go to just uh a walk through uh
uh i'm not going to go through every
every thing in this laundry list but
here's the laundry list from f sharp
five the ones in bold are the ones i
will be
i will be talking about today
and then we a year later
uh november
november
we did the same thing with f sharp six
big long laundry list of things
and
uh
and again i'm not going to be able to
get to go through every small feature
probably
so you if you want to find out about all
the features
uh
you can go to f sharp fs lang design
which is where we do all the design
open design f-sharp community
process for for f-sharp
you can come to the top of the repo here
and you can see all the rfcs from all
the previous versions you can come to f
sharp five
check out all the all the details and
follow through
these are great resources they're
technical documentation but they also
link through to the implementation they
also link through to the original
suggestion so you can see the full
history of house of how we went about
the design process and all the
discussion
and um
and so if you're interested in
contributing to the f sharp language
design you can
uh get involved uh but these are a great
resource for how we do the design
process
uh
probably
since since it's here and since i've got
a fair amount of time
one of my favorite things about f sharp
six
is that we put in this printf as a
binary format you can now you've sent b
but look at that rfc number isn't that
good for a binary format uh edition um i
was just so that was luck pure luck but
uh it's how it came out okay
so f sharp six has a whole lot of great
things right so let's talk about some of
those uh the first is we went in f sharp
five
we went and did string interpolation
it's a wonderful feature
okay now i'll show you a little bit
about what that actually means in
practice
so i'm going to do some
scripting here in fsharp interactive
here
programming
okay so a typical piece of string
interpolation is this
it's where you get to use values in the
middle and so this string will format as
i say 1
is 1 and 3.14
is
pi
there
now as many of you will know fsharp
already has a kind of form of string
formatting
where you could do this kind of thing
okay
and you would put
you would not have this and you would
not have
this and you would put
x and pi at the end here it's c style
formatting strings and one of the big
problems with putting in string
interpolation was how what do we do
to about what do we do about having two
features for the same thing
and
each is
one you know one is good in one way and
one is good in another way one gives you
uh this this sort of love lovely kind of
inline syntax for for for strings the
other one gives you strong typing okay
so if i
if i for instance put percent s in here
then i'll get a thing saying this is not
a string okay and that's actually really
valuable for pinning down your
types
okay
so one of the key things we did in the
design process was to work out how to
square the circle on this how to get how
to how to how to triangulate these
and in fact
you can
what that means is that in string
interpolation you can put
uh
these percent d thing to say actually
this thing in here whatever this
expression is x x plus x plus x okay
this has to be an integer i'm going to
constrain that to be an integer and this
one here for instance you can constrain
to be a string and you'll immediately
get an error saying that thing there is
not actually a string
and that's really important because
otherwise this expression in the middle
here can be really anything and it will
just call tostring on that expression
and it's very loosely typed so string
interpolation is a very sloppy feature
right uh it it without this now you
don't have to use it and of course most
the time when you don't have to use the
percents you can just use it as i have
before
and uh
and and
but
the the important thing from the design
perspective is we got the best of both
worlds between these features by
combining
uh the strong allowing you to optionally
use everything you've learned about
percent d formatting percent uh percent
formatting and and use it in the context
of string interpolation you can also do
that a little bit further you could if
you if you know about using formatting
using those things so for instance you
now want to start doing some formatting
percent not
to get two decimal places down here you
can use that either using the dot net
c-sharp way
uh or you can do it using the the dot uh
using these kind of
uh percent um placeholder kind of way
uh
now there is actually an uh for those in
the technical details there's some
there's some other technical details
about how you can write for instance
your own logging functions
which uh which maybe post process the
string with the word log at the top up
here and so and then you can still use
string interpolation even with that with
that kind of uh with with that kind of
setup
along here so just to
run that example and if i do that then
when it prints the number is result
today it says log the number is result
today and so you can kind of in
interleave
a little bit this is this k printf thing
interleaves some extra
some extra printing along with your
string output
okay
so uh string interpolation let me just
show you the rfc for string
interpolation
is
here
it was the very first rfc ever created
for f sharp in 2014
and uh it went through
[Music]
three iterations and each time three
design iterations i think three
prototypes
and i'm just extremely happy with that
we took our time over this and
eventually got to a point that combines
these
combines these elements
and you can see the design principles we
used
and read through them and you can look
through the detailed technical design
and uh and and so on
all the way down
okay
so why are we doing it improved
readability reduce errors more succinct
less to learn
okay
and you can see how that's playing into
those original goals of f sharp string
interpolation totally fits with the
original design goals of f sharp
succinct robust performance
so we managed to align with c sharp you
can take c sharp code and move it across
and
adjust it but we also get this strong
typing by unifying with printf
and we allow it to be used with printf
and and friends
okay
okay so the next thing uh next thing
i'll call out in f f sharp five
was that we added the ability to open
the static content of types okay so i'll
just
give a very short demo of what that
means
so for example you can open type
system.math
and that allows you just to use the min
and max functions for instance to
directly these overloaded functions here
and you'll see here that min is now
overloaded
between all the different
things
this is something quite different for f
sharp and c sharp in a way c sharp broke
one of its original design principles
one of the original design principles of
c sharp was that
if you had something overloaded
it would always be qualified in some way
uh
so
um so they they broke that principle and
allow you just to have these unqualified
single identifier overloaded things
and
we eventually decided in f sharp that
there were enough c important c sharp
libraries using this
that we were going to allow the same
thing in f sharp i have some qualms
about adding this to f sharp i'll talk
about that more in a bit
you can use it on f sharp to find things
you can define your own type here like
this
and you can do open type c and then you
can just i mean p here is now referring
just to that static member p okay
and something here is now referring to
that to that um
to that something
okay
okay okay so
uh
why are we doing this because it does
uh allow these sort of increased express
these dsls these single dsls are often
often sort of
focused a lot on succinctness and sort
of uh dropping you into the domain
rather into without making you less
aware that you're embedding the domain
into the programming language and so you
get this ultrasync mode of programming
so um
[Music]
now these single word functions can
actually also be take named optional
parameter arguments okay they do it does
increase the kind of expressivity of
what you can do in kind of dsls uh
embedded dsls
uh but that comes with a lot of
downsides and
so there's some particular dsls
particularly those used for apache spark
on azure uh so for the for the dot net
and c sharp f sharp support for for big
data programming with with apache spark
and they use these um dsl they use this
this open type uh extensively through
their their presentation
uh
be very very cautious about using this
in team in team situations uh okay
because it can uh
it
obviously there are problems with this
this kind of feature you open type if
you do open type from one dsl and open
type on another dsl and in into the same
context then the words get and they're
using the same words the same overloads
then things kind of start to go wrong
okay
the rule is that the second one wins we
don't allow overload sets to emerge from
two things but it could be that your
dsls kind of become less useful
but between these kind of conflicts that
happen
uh and
um people are obviously going to have
you know a harder time code reviewing
this kind of thing uh without if they
haven't got strong tooling support
uh to tell them where things are
resolving to so just be careful about
using this and don't inflict it on you
yourself or your friends or your team
without real thought about the
consequences you know good f sharp
programmers think about their team that
they're working with and how they use
the features of the language to uh
to to to make their team their the whole
team more productive
okay
so in f sharp five we
finally did what you know we kind of
should have done as soon as nougat got
created which is to allow you to do hash
our nougat in f sharp scripts
and so what does it look like you do
hash r nougat newton soft.json or give a
specific version number
you can see i'm actually not in an
fsharp script in this file but you can
i'm in a dot fs file not a dot fsx but
i've just put it in a comment at the top
so i can send you can still send
interactive from this kind of thing
and you can see what happens i've i've
referenced two two libraries here i've
shop data for fluent
and you can see
it's it's gone through and processed
those
and uh
now i have
access to those fsharp.data.whatever
okay
i've also referenced some in my project
context over here
but if you're in a script
you can just happily use this kind of
working and it will work in both the
developer tools and the ide before you
even execute anything and
i might as well just show that
open a new script
script
there we go
okay so you can see i haven't actually
executed anything from this particular
script and you immediately just get
strong typing through to that set of
packages that you've referenced
so people
do
people who are experienced with doing
python programming
look at this feature and they say this
is the number one feature for python
programmers and it links back into what
i said originally what are python
programmers after okay they're fine with
succinctness they don't want more
succinctly they've got that they've got
too much of that probably if anything
right
but they do want features like this
which unless you lock down the packages
you're referencing okay even better you
can combine this now with a global.json
in your script directory
and the editing tools will take note of
that global.json to say we're using a
particular version of the.net sdk
okay
and that means you can really lock down
your scripts to just be
completely trusted to be completely
trustworthy you know what dot net
framework they're running against
or uh you know what um and what policy
is applied to that and you know what uh
exact what exactly what packages are
being used
you can also specify remote package
sources
uh they have to be authenticated just
via the act
as your this is this active directory or
whatever integrated um authentication
you you've got we don't allow separately
authenticated feeds from f-sharp scripts
you have to do those from project code
uh
okay so
um so that's a hash i
down there just in case uh and so the
docs for all this are all online it's a
very simple feature and uh it lets you
get going with all sorts of great
scripting programming just with a few
a few lines it's great
okay
okay so on f sharp five i i now want to
talk about a a feature that's much more
at the kind of programming language
design and the other the things i've
talked about uh have been sort of
practical
happy features uh you have nice
everyone's happy with things like string
interpolation
uh this next one is a bit of a different
one because it looks so subtle it's so
strange it's much more in the kind of
expressivity kind of line uh for f sharp
and in the way it's outside those three
themes and there's not really aimed at c
sharp or python programmers but i'm
still really happy to have done this one
in the f-sharp language design and it
extends this thing called f-sharp
computation expressions which is anyone
doing f sharp will know what those are
that's why we have all these different
things that kind of come from different
programming languages iterator methods
or query expressions or comprehensions
or async or async sequences
in say c sharp or
other programming languages and we kind
of put them all into this one feature of
f sharp where you have some
computational modality you have a
modality and then you have some code
okay
and uh that's called a computation
expression in f sharp and you can do all
sorts of amazing uh kind of things with
this
uh if you take a look at what that means
c sharp say has five different features
all of these these things down the left
and they sort of all become the same
thing in f sharp however they all just
become the they all just become a
computation
expression i mean you get different
computation expressions but they're one
kind of language feature under the hood
there's a whole history to how this came
about you can see my some of my talks
from during the year on the history of f
sharp but this the fact that we have
this thing called computation
expressions that lets you do so many
different things and many many more as
well
uh
just is one of these
really unifying things about the f-sharp
language designer that does make the
whole language design simpler end-to-end
because we're not just adding
more and more kind of complicated things
uh down which all work a bit differently
we kind of just add this one
we have this one feature computational
expressions
but there's something that computational
can't do one of the things they can do
uh in in f sharp so four
is this kind of let bang bang this
binding uh this like it's like a weight
await a weight or whatever kind of thing
you're doing left bangla bangla bang and
the point about computational
expressions is some magic happens in
between as you say a weight
or
or you yield from a com from a
computation or you're doing a co-routine
or something like that uh
and so you have this sort of magic in
between and eventually it finishes with
a return or a bunch of yields or
something like that
but but what what it can't do is this uh
what's called applicative binding or
sort of this sort of simultaneous sort
of parallel kind of binding where you
kick off a whole bunch of things in
and i use the term very very loosely in
parallel it doesn't mean there's
actually i i don't necessarily
in a way there's there's two things
going on these things all kick off
together
but and then they and then they sort of
some magic happens uh to combine them
together and then they return and it's
as much the fact that this is a
two-phase thing
that makes this quite this this
interesting okay that you want to have
a static composition which
on the left here and then a run time
over on the right and so for instance
this might be making your graph and this
might be running your graph
okay
so uh
so from a language design point of view
all we're doing is allowing you to add
do and bang let bang and bang and bang
in these in these things
so that that's the feature let bang and
bang in
computations uh
and if you
when you use that it maps to a thing
called bind return or merge sources
and uh and as i said this relates
directly to the last f sharp london
meetup before the pandemic
and it's often used for these things
which in the i guess in the haskell
world are called applicatives uh and
these sort of two-phase computations and
they separate composition from running
uh you have a static composition and
then a dynamic run
and for
for example in the static phase you
might make a graph
and then before you run you might
pre-allocate a whole lot of buffers for
that graph and then you actually
run your your your your your code
uh and there are lots of great examples
of using this say for validation or
graphs of fixed size i will show
some
examples
uh
let me
let me just point you to some
documentation on this
so i have a blog post you can search for
design
design applicatives
where we talk about the various styles
for doing applicatives and here you can
see the let bang and bang and bang
so the first part of the composition and
then the final part of the composition
here
so one one area where you might do this
is to build a bunch of validators okay
so uh this is where this is
this is where you
validate five different
inputs
and then you and then you
you you build or
and then you and then you're giving the
result the composition the runtime for
once all the inputs come in so you're
building your network of validators and
then at runtime you actually give your
give your uh your you the result of the
composing of the validations
okay i will give a longer example of
this now
and it is
so in this example what we're doing is
we're building a graph of nodes okay so
we have our node type here node is this
abstract class
node dirty here
and we're going to do a few things along
the way such as counting the number of
nodes
and each node is it's going to be an
imperative graph so we're going to have
these nodes here and they're going to
link back to the nodes that they depend
on it's going to be a calculation graph
an explicit calculation graph
okay so let's go through and define our
node type
and we're going to have a couple of
different nodes node types a node of t
here and then a recalc node here that uh
that that uses a function to recompute
its value here
okay so let's
sorry
okay
and here is a constant node that is just
always gives back the particular value x
and here's a input node that is takes a
value v but where the input can change
here when you set the value
and now even though this is an
imperative structure
that uses mutation you can still define
a
computational expression that allows you
to build
these things so let's just do
uh
sorry just to take this out from and
okay so we define ourselves a node
builder
and we define the input node and then we
define
uh sorry function to build input nodes
and then we define three input nodes
here
and then we use our node builder to
start composing these nodes together so
this function builds a new node which
takes in those three nodes
and then does a return
of some computation like this
returning the sum of each of their nodes
and in this node here
we do it a different way which is where
we use where we use sequential binding
so this is the difference between doing
the simultaneous binding i showed and
between doing the sequential binding one
two three le bang le bang le bang
okay and now we can that's the two
different ways of composing nodes
and now we can do a bit of work to see
which one is more efficient okay
so now if we uh
if we compare what we've done here okay
how many nodes did we create when doing
this simultaneous one and then what with
the test here is simply it takes
it it uh
it
creates the graph here this n represents
the the final output node of the graph
and then it starts modifying the input
nodes and and gets an adjusted value so
it propagates the propagates the changes
through the graph
and and we see how many new nodes did we
create along the way
and if you look at what we did with and
bang we created one new node okay which
was the composition node and then we
started modifying and no no new nodes
got created okay because we had a static
composition and one static output and
then we just can just modify those
outputs but when you use magnetic
binding at the la bangla bangla bang
here
and you can see that we actually created
4 000
new nodes and that's of course when you
modified those things with that chain of
things then when you modify the first
one or the second one or the third one
you've got to rerun that chain endlessly
okay so one so so even though it's just
looks so quite subtle let bang and bang
and bang versus left bang left band left
bang there's actually a huge performance
difference between those two and you
might say to yourself well what happens
if i only want the high performance one
okay well what you do is you in your but
in your um
in your
um in your computation expression
builder you can you can exclude certain
kinds of binding
okay so you can comment out this binding
here
you can comment out uh
let's see comment at this one
one two and bind
and you only allow this uh
this applicative binding let bangla
bang and vang
through bind return
and
now you can see that you actually get an
error here
saying that this is not allowed okay so
in fact this would allow if you this
would mean that your team
is only allowed to do static
compositions of
of of of nodes uh okay in a way that
won't actually create new nodes at what
is effectively the the runtime for the
graph
okay and you can if you like as you saw
in what i had before you can uh
define
two kinds of builders one is for node
static
and one is for node dynamic
which allows uh we where the node
dynamic allows extra kind of operations
extra kinds of kind of compositions and
uh and then you can code review for uses
of node dynamic to make sure they're
only being used you're only getting
dynamic creations of things as uh where
where where you in where you really need
them
okay okay
so
it's a interesting subtle feature
it's it's it's on definitely on
you know
it
used correctly it it absolutely
simplifies a certain kind of composition
it's obviously a corner case in the
language it's rarely used but it's still
just really sweet and
interesting form of composition to add
to the language
okay at the other end of the spectrum we
uh we removed a dot
okay and this is sort of the full
spectrum of uh programming language
design from where you kind of think
about these fancy forms of composition
and their impact on you know performance
and the like and then you kind of think
about
uh what you actually need to do to your
programming language because it used to
be the case that in order to do
array or in associative lookup in f
sharp you had to do
uh dot of index okay and now as of f
sharp six
you don't need to do that anymore and
you can just do uh expression of index
uh so
why
uh
why did we
put in all the effort to make this
this change okay well it's it it it's
we were just losing people for
absolutely no reason and i i know this
because
one of my good friends who
absolutely loves f sharp he works in
machine learning and uh and vision
research he just said every time he gave
a talk on f sharp
he would just show people he'd just show
some code
and with and people would ask why do you
need the dot
and then you would say well you just
need the dot in f sharp that's how it
works we we got it originally from
o'camel there are reasons for it in the
design heritage of o'camel but
uh they aren't good reasons okay and and
he said people just turn off people just
like say well i don't okay i don't need
to worry about that language okay i can
forget about that okay and so
what i like about this change that we
made is it's actually making f sharp
more like it was always intended to be
okay there was never any good reason
never any sufficiently good reason to be
different yeah as as you saw with string
interpolation and other things we don't
we try not to differ from the industry
norms we try to you know
we a lot of the f-sharp design was about
making
the uh making the language more like a
normal
industry programming language and so
this is in that theme moving it making a
sharp better by moving it towards it
already was which i think if you compare
that to what say c sharp is having to do
in a way c sharp is having is always
trying to become something that it
wasn't originally okay it's trying to
starts off being this object highly
object-oriented language and you know it
adds these great features but
it's always sort of struggling against
its initial
its initial um
starting point but for me this is just
about making f sharp better by moving it
to what it already was intended to be
okay so in fsharp six we also added task
support fsharp already had async support
but uh there
but it um
it's a different it was a different type
to tasks
and so we can see that in code like
like this
so here's some typical
f sharp async code and this is asian
async code that is interoperating with
tasks okay
uh
you
okay so if you don't if we didn't have
this await task here for example
then you'd get an error saying this
thing is uh is it producing a task but
we're expecting an async if you're going
to bind to it here
so you had to put in this weight task
and if you uh didn't
put that thing at the end you'd get an
async and let's say your job is to
actually produce a task you'd have to do
start as task so this is where you
eliminate tasks and this is where you
introduce tasks
and fsharp async is actually really in
some ways it's better than task but
there's just a lot of task-based code
around in the dotnet world and there are
lots of good reasons just to make it
simpler to write tasks directly so
nowadays you can with fsharp 6
it's
built in that you can simply
change this to task here
and you can remove this part here and
you can remove this part here
and you've got a thing that uses a task
function whether that's from some api or
some code you've already written and
you're producing a task here
and otherwise things are very very much
the same but there are some differences
you need to be aware so task is a single
mutable sort of a weightable register it
has hot start so the task starts
immediately so in in fsharp async that's
not the case so in fsharp async you'd
have to you'd have to
just say we did this
then you have to start that async
directly
so yeah in a separate phase so you do
use function 2
[Music]
three you do async dot start
uh
sorry for instance run
synchronously
okay so but tasks aren't like that when
you have task code
you the code starts running immediately
so as soon as you execute some function
this task starts running until its first
await point
so tasks are hot start
they also don't do cancellation checks
along the way and they don't propagate a
cancellation token automatically one of
the really nice things about facing code
is it propagates that cancellation token
all the way through you can just makes
life much simpler that's not the case
with tasks
you have to explicitly do that and they
also don't support this thing with tail
calls you have to be a little bit
careful about recursive tasks and that's
all got to do with the limitations of
net tasks but nevertheless there's still
an awful lot of case cases where you
just want to write tasks directly
and
so it's great to have that support built
in for the language it's also debugging
can be a lot better than async
and uh
and
the performance can also be better than
f sharp async
for when that matters
okay
so just to conclude with a few more
points we added
so we did some deprecation we actually
started deprecating quite a lot of
things for instance there was this very
old thing called the ml compatibility
mode right back from f 1.0 that's all
been deprecated and limited to f sharp
5.0 and before
there are also these things called
reference cells which use these
operators bang and colon equals
okay so just to give a sample of that
let me
let me just undo here a bit
fine okay so
deprecation
at
five
okay so you now get a deprecation here
saying the the use of this operator from
the f library is deprecated please use a
more explicit form
okay
uh and and used to be able to do sort of
bang r uh
uh like that
uh and it says please don't do that
please use dot value now and this kind
of programming is actually almost never
needed in f sharp
uh and in any case so you you because
these days you can nearly always just do
let mutable r equal this like this
and then you just use r directly like
that
so we decided to
deprecate that through a very soft
deprecation just that informational
warning that comes up to saying please
don't do this
and
that's very much a very major reason
it's because of that bang r that we had
is just obviously so confusing to people
coming from python and c-sharp and we
just we just can't have that in the
language in the long term we have to get
rid of that kind of confusion for people
coming from that
from from that world uh and and there
are cases where this you know uh
uh
where you see this kind of code
you know this kind of thing false
and finished
is
true or something
sort of while
not
while
not bang finished
dot dot dot that sort of thing
uh of course people don't you know
people coming from the c sharp world
will see this i mean we can't we just
can't have this in the language anyway
it's gone i'll just delete all of that
okay so that's uh soft so don't use
those operators and you'll get soft
deprecation messages
f-sharp compiler service now fully
multi-threaded no reactor queue the ides
are way more responsive visual studio
2022 is our 64-bit
lots of other major performance
improvements in their compiler the ide
the tooling they're in the announcement
blogs take it take a look at those
one thing i am going to show next is to
do with uh
on the tooling side is to do with
pipeline debugging
and in this uh i would since i'm just
running out of time i will
just show that here and i'm going to
press f5 to see
hopefully i it builds okay
yep
okay
so i
so so
now in f sharp six you can set
break points on pipeline stages
like this
so uh any any of these down down the way
and
if you take a careful look down the
bottom left you'll see you can see what
the input to the pipeline is and this is
actually an example which is doing some
screen scraping from a wikipedia site to
do doc the british tv show doctor who
and it's getting the episode list to
doctor who and who were the directors
you can see the dialects here
and you can see that was our original
input and then we did some filtering of
that actually nothing got filtered out
you can see that there's nothing being
filtered 261 and then you can see that
we only searched for the dialect
episodes here
and they had a full 280
uh
no we're grouping no we're grouping by
whether the thing contains daleks
or not
and then oh no that's the result of the
grouping this is between uh
193 episodes didn't contain daleks and
193 25 episodes did contain
daleks in the first few years of doctor
who
okay so you can see pipeline debugging
this is one of my favorite features of
fsharp 6. i use it all the time
just stepping through the compiler it's
just so much more enjoyable it's one of
the first times we've actually done a
debugging feature that is specifically
related to something strongly associated
with f sharp this pipelining thing
so uh really very happy with how that
that one works uh there's also some work
on improving the how we show shadowing
values in the debugger
list and array expressions have had like
a four time performance improvement in
how we compile those constructs we no
longer do them in the link kind of way
but just generate this really fast
generator code
for them
and uh you can take a look at
those we've also from the f sharp
community had this improved map and set
performance by viktor bavakov
and just that was in fsharp five and
just massive improvements to the
performance of uh the core map and set
data structures
so we've also done some dock
improvements there's loads of
almost all the functions in fsharp.com
come with proper examples now and you
can also turn on some xml dock checking
in your
in your projects if you go through and
put this on worn on 3390 you do have to
turn this on explicitly for various
compat reasons
uh so one on 3390
and you come to your error list you'll
see here for example that i've mistyped
the tag on my xml docs so you'll get xml
doc checking in the ide
uh for
and it'll it'll check for instance if
you you've given um a
documentation for each parameter in your
functions and so on
okay
uh
so
i i do want to say just what a huge
incredibly collaborative effort this has
been here's the thanks and
acknowledgments for f sharp six so many
people have contributed to this from
across the f-sharp community they listed
out two people uh call out nino flora
flores uh and hadrian tang here hadrian
is a 19 year old student from hong kong
university he contributed about four or
five of the features in f sharp six so
isn't it just fantastic to see people
coming into the dot net community with
you know uh who are without with that
kind of energy right at the start of
their
of their careers as well but loads of
people have uh have contributed
okay and that's it thanks very much i
don't know if we're taking questions or
not in the talks i guess i'm kind of out
of time so maybe we will take the
questions outside
uh unless we'll take one question
any anybody got a question and barely
see you all
anyway we'll take questions outside
just here
thanks
you